déjà vous vous avez voulu analyser les
images très vite pourquoi parce que vous
êtes dit je veux savoir la vérité
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que si
vous avez tout votre vérité vous avez
défendu aux éclairs mais tes ongles
exactement on a été touché par le
témoignage de michel je veux bien
comprendre que c'est l'empathie parce
que moi aussi j'ai été touché comme vous
et moi aussi quand j'ai vu les premières
images
mais ensuite quelque chose vous êtes dit
que vous avez les programmes ils ont
déconné mais non c'est pire que déconner
c'est à dire que quand on voit les cinq
secondes on s'est dit tout de suite mais
ils ont rien à faire dans la police et
jean la tête mais en plus on nous parle
de propos racistes
rien à faire de la police et selon le
premier rapport au premier abord parce
qu on veut être honnête on veut pas
qu'on sait que c'est notre uniforme mais
ensuite sans qu'un peu vous êtes dit je
vais enquêter quand même pour voir ce
qui met déjà c'est incongru c'est
impossible enfin trois policiers qui
vont tabassé un mec pour rien juste
parce qu'il n'a pas de masque ils vont
traiter de sale [ __ ] mais j'ai 23 ans
de police j'ai 23 ans de police jamais
vu un truc pareil
alors elle tient pas très sympa cette
affaire elle tient là donnez nous votre
version ce soir et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé les images pour vous ont été
manipulés qu'est ce qui s'est passé
toute façon vous regardez le site
outsiders on parle de 20 minutes de
tabassage pour garder la minute il n'y a
pas beaucoup de travail à faire 12h20
vous regardez la vidéo il a écrit huit
minutes parce qu'ils allaient totalité
de la vidéo elle fait huit minutes
il ya deux vidéos a tancé alors il y
aura deux il ya une deuxième vidéo qui
fait quatre minutes 55 à l'extérieur peu
importe voilà avait été prise à
l'extérieur il était menotté au sol et
il a pris une série de coups de poing au
visage alors qu'il était menotté aux
salles d'eau qui avait pas de violence
légitime à ce moment j'avais une super
belle vue attendez bien la vidéo est
disponible sur le net
il était menotté au sol il a été tabassé
il a pris une série de coups de poing au
visage par un policier âgé de 21 ans
plus précisément parce que j'ai eus j'ai
jeté un oeil au dossier et les images
démontrent clairement que il hérite
voilà et il y avait une vingtaine de
policiers autour qui n'ont absolument
pas vrai a écouté voilà c'est bien lancé
ma deuxième émission parce qu'on fait
justement la deux et la deuxième
émission sur la deuxième vidéo et il a
perdu 0 en sets 6 0 il a perdu l'usagé
de son bras et la 180 jours d'itt et et
quand on sait que la mesure légale
c'est-à-dire que le seuil légal qui
permet de caractériser un délit
un autre est fixé à 8 jours d'itt et et
là on est à 180 jours d'itt et et
s'avère plus de 20 fois
justement le lieu on va dire le seuil
qui est imposé par le code de procédure
pénale on se dit que c'est pas rien
c'est à dire on pas là on parle comme si
quelque chose d'irrationnel
vous pouvez avoir un avis face à un
autre on a quand même un type là qui est
qui qui en situation de handicap à la
suite de cette intervention alors
justement non moi j'aimerais avoir ma
mais on va te faire ici c'est ben vrai
policier
pardon ben vous n'êtes pas vrai police
papoue si oui vous êtes un magistrat
c'est à dire que le procès si le
tribunal vous avez ski et les fausses
notes ici c'est pas un prime la la
mauricie si son cadet et clarifie les
choses sérieuses
et là c'est l abbé pierre qui était ici
mais là c'est l'outsider c'est pas des
vrais journalistes moi je suis pas un
vrai policier
toi t'es pas un vrai présentateur tout
est faux on arrête quoi je veux dire là
laurent bruneau donnez-nous votre
version wii mais je l'expliquais version
de l'histoire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les faits
alors écoutez les faits sont simples mes
collègues ils sont en train de contrôler
ils sont attirés à l'intérieur ils sont
attirés l'intérieur donc c'est quoi
alors ils sont donc on veut on veut
reprendre la sphère dont on a eu la
version de michel loua brin la version
de bordeaux bruno donc pour vous donc
michel est clair donc rentrer dans son
studio
là il est interpellé pour attendait
alors déjà ce qu'il faut déjà bien noter
c'est que moi j'ai pas que c'est la
procédure d'accord toutes les
informations 100% des informations de
vue c'est sur le c sur internet alors
pas je me permets d'intervenir
oui parce que monsieur dit dans sa vidéo
présente moi j'ai regardé j'étais très
curieux de savoir quelles étaient les
faits nouveaux que je pouvais dont je
pouvais prendre connaissance d'excel
quelque chose d'une à france nouvelle
qui est qui qui n'avait pas été mise à
disposition du public auparavant j'ai
pas trouvé
moi ce que monsieur affirme que les
policiers ont pas eu effectivement dans
la presse la possibilité de s'exprimer
c'est normal parce qu'ils ont été
incarcérés mais je pense qu'en france
aujourd'hui on incarcère pas les gens
comme ça plein certifiés dans toutes ces
affaires qui sont peints qui sont pas là
il juge a décidé de les mettre en prison
est aujourd'hui sont sous contrôle
judiciaire donc on n'est pas dans une
posture qui est neutre
alors vous êtes ancien fonctionnaire
moyen aura des comme vous on se portera
juillet deux chinois c'est faux vous
faut devenir ministre de l'intérieur
drôle